[Musique]
on grandit tout avec ce même rêve celui
de trouver le grand amour auprès d'un
chevalier en armure étincelante et de
vivre heureuse comme dans les contes de
fées le problème c'est que ça n'existe
que dans les contes de fées
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va n'ayez crainte j'ai été
désarçonné plus brutalement et par des
montures plus rapide que votre destrier
d'acier il n'a pas une égratignure mais
apparemment il se prend pour un
chevalier du 14e siècle
messire cool christopher frédéric lion's
de norwich pour vous servir en purée
c'est entièrement ma faute
d'où est-ce que provient cette mélodie
lyrique de la radio je vais l'aider
jusqu'à ce qu'il retrouve la mémoire
ici le dangereux tu peux me croire il
est inoffensif pour commencer je pense
qu'on devrait mettre à jour votre
garde-robe de moins quelques siècles
bonsoir donc ce soir je vous laisse vous
habiller
vous savez que le voyage d'un temps ça
n'existe pas n'est ce pas j'ai voyagé
jusqu'ici et il importe peu que je
comprenne de quelle façon
un chevalier se doit d'agir avec courage
et vertus d'apporter son aide à ceux qui
en ont besoin surtout reste où tu es
j'ai bien peur de devoir rentrer chez
moi
tu crois vraiment que rentrer dans son
petit délire améliore la situation
qui sommes-nous pour lui dire qu'il
n'est pas ce qu'il dit être vous êtes
sûr de ne pas être une sorcière et si
cole était vraiment ce qu'il prétend
être
et s'il y avait des choses qui dépassent
notre compréhension
apparemment vous avez tous les deux
besoin de faire examiner
vous n'êtes pas obligé de partie je n'ai
pas le choix
[Musique]
où que vous soyez je ne veux c'est être
nulle part ailleurs
mais personne ne peut aller contre son
destin
joli réflexe prenez garde à vous
[Musique]